first if you had the opportunity to swap
roles with anybody in the Star Wars film
franchise who would you choose and why
I'd say Adam everybody everybody wants
kylo Ren well he gets to do so much fun
stuff and I mean obviously a lot of that
has to do with his brilliant performing
but especially in this one actually he
he has like some real funny moments he's
obviously a mean guy but there's so much
I think really is his performance
there's so much vulnerability and
insecurity within that they it's it's
yeah it's just fun but I don't think
anyone could do it like he does one of
my favorite qualities of kylo Ren those
vulnerable very human moments that you
gets so a sillier question because
everybody is super into baby Yoda right
now so we're playing baby Yoda's first
so think babies first yeah if you had
the opportunity to witness baby Yoda's
first fill in the blank what would you
pick and how would it go down here's
what I'm gonna say I did the English
version of Studio Ghibli film called
only yesterday and in it one of the
little girls is pineapple for the first
time and it's like unlike face blows off
so I would love to see baby Oda eat
pineapple for the first time I love that
answer
yeah I also wanted to ask you obviously
without spoiling anything about the
film's ending just in particular how the
ending of the final film that we're
gonna see on screen compares to what
Collin shared with you years ago do you
know what I don't think Colin told me
how it ended yeah I think we went for
dinner and he talked about loose things
about like characters and things but I
never knew what the ending was gonna be
but weirdly someone I work with I said
what would you really want to see like
in the film and they guessed they didn't
guess that that was the ending but they
were like oh this is what I'd love to
see I was like that's part of it whoever
that is I am so impressed because every
theory I come up with is wrong of it but
you don't know that you haven't seen it
maybe one of your theories is right now
the last three movies are fun if you had
a name an unsung hero of rise of
Skywalker who would it be
we know JJ we know you
but is there I know a PA or someone at
craft service the kind of major day when
you really need my unsung here I was Lee
who is my driver he provided me with a
peanut butter and banana sandwich every
day when we were doing the fight he took
me safely to him from work every day
listen to my schpeel
makes me laugh and I love him a lot
anything that answered that question
with peanut butter in it was the right
exactly so this trilogy is coming to a
close there's no doubt in my mind that
Star Wars will be alive and thriving on
the big screen for years to come and
eventually we might get a new lead
ensemble so having gone through this
process what one piece of advice would
you give a new actor stepping into this
franchise well John made the good point
yesterday that we'd be feeling jealous
of those people so I'd be like really
enjoy it because you're really lucky to
be there to be surrounded by great
people I don't know it's really hard
because like I had a drink with Kelly
when she was cast I drink with Naomi
but it's so unique NYX everyone's
singular experience that you can say
have fun enjoy it don't too much
pressure in yourself and there are
things that individuals experience that
I don't think there's any one thing but
probably just trying to enjoy it